when you talk about the saturday night
live years in your book it astounds me
that your impression of saturday night
live was hey i'm not doing well here
i don't mean to imply you know everyone
was really really nice to me it wasn't
like i don't have any stories like oh
i was a victim it was just that i found
that because i had a one-year contract i
didn't feel like i was there
now starting university i felt like you
know i got 21 shows or something
to and i got to prove myself they were
also paying us more money than they'd
ever paid people so i felt like come on
be funny be funny
right and no matter what you go through
if you could kill saturday night have a
great party
go out to a hip lunch you know with
people uh
you know the odion or something whatever
it was hip then and then
by sunday night it was like oh
ring goes in tomorrow what i have no
ideas so you'd
fake it you know as a fan i was like wow
what is martin short doing on there he's
an sctv guy it would seem like right out
of left field you know what i mean do
you know i was very hesitant
uh dick ebersole phoned me and said do
you want to do seren live
and and i kind of thought i i
and he said you know here's who we're
trying to get we're trying to get
christopher guest
harry shearer who had spinal tap out
that song which was just
huge the most genius and also so genius
yes
and billy crystal and i kind of said
well you know call me back when you get
them
right you know in other words you would
not go do this unless they had that
stuff
and then he phoned me up and said that
we got him and so i was when they had a
little press conference in l.a to
announce the new cast i was the surprise
last person they dragged you out as the
big surprise yeah yeah
was there a competition no i mean maybe
it's politically correct not to say
there was but
when you're in that thing it's almost
like a comedy um battlefield like you
want to be the star you want to be great
i didn't i didn't honest to god i swear
to you because i had come from sctv
where it wasn't about that collaborative
i just wanted to survive
i just wanted i didn't want to be in
nine scenes i wanted to be in
two scenes uh where i and usually i was
just in two scenes
right and again after the third show i
went back i had a new little baby
we went back to toronto for a week and
uh and i came back
and i had a meeting with dick ebersole
and i said i want to leave
you said in your book had you been more
relaxed about saturday live had you been
like me
watching it and saying oh my god this
guy's brilliant on it you might have
stayed a few more seasons
i don't think i would have stayed longer
because it was always
a one-year contract and i had a
nine-month-old baby
right and i just but i i think i would
have enjoyed myself there more
and by the time the year kept moving on
i was figuring out how to do it i was
calming down
you seem defensive i'm not being
defensive you're the one who's being
defensive
why is it always the other person who's
being defensive
have you ever asked yourself that why
don't you ask yourself that
did it freak you out doing live
television after doing sctv and being
able to edit i mean
it is kind of i remember i remember the
uh after the first show i went
to get a tape on monday right and davey
wilson the director said i just saw him
he said what are you doing
i said oh i was gonna get the tape don't
do that don't look at it
it just it happened it existed it's gone
move on really why why do you think but
don't you think you improve when you
look at the tape of your own
i do actually yeah and i mean when you
would come on saturday night live and do
like at gremlin you know that that stuff
were there times you would do it in
rehearsal and it was funnier and then
you'd have to go out and do it live
and it wouldn't be as funny no i
actually think
that the weird thing about people who
succeed on saturday live
is that even though it's this weird
thing where you have to
achieve in the dress rehearsal or
they'll cut it right
you have to also know that you can only
have one opening night you can only have
one moment where you're good at just
going to go for it so subconsciously
you're holding something back
right one thing i used to do is i didn't
like the cue cards
and i used to um would you memorize the
entire script
well i and then i would go off i'd get
lost a little bit and i'd improvise and
almost say look at the window
you know yeah but that screws the
director up right because yeah
so i said to them uh i remember the
first they i said no no i i don't need
cue cards oh no you have to have cue
cards those are the rules
i'd say oh good so i'd take out my
contact lens
it was now a blur because i didn't i
just didn't want to
do that thing